10 Uhr 30 vormittags und die fast 400
Freiwilligen drängeln sich,
um endlich rein zu dürfen ins Terminal.
Dabei ist in Zeiten von
Corona Abstand geboten.
Doch echte Flughafen-Fans hält
das nicht von einem Tag
als Komparse im neuen
Hauptstadtflughafen ab.
Ich bin flugzeugbegeistert,
ich bin reisebegeistert
und ich lass mir natürlich so ’ne Gelegenheit
nicht entgehen.
Bin viel schon geflogen,
ich kenn die Originalplanung von 65.
Schauen wir, was davon übriggeblieben ist.
Nun will ich mal sehen,
wie das so funktionieren soll.
Insgesamt 9.000 Freiwillige sind
seit Anfang Juli im Einsatz,
zweimal die Woche wird getestet.
Die Koffer sind unterschiedlich schwer
bepackt, schließlich soll das Szenario
echt sein und da fangen die
Komplikationen für manche schon an.
Das hat doch nichts mit dem Flug zu tun,
du sollst doch nicht das Gepäckstück
... stellst du das wieder hin!
Nehmen Sie ein Gepäckstück.
Das ist ein Gepäckstück!
Ja,
stimmt.
Jeder noch so kleine Fehler
soll heute gefunden werden.
Am Ende des Tages geben
die Komparsen ihr Urteil ab.
Pünktlich Ende Oktober soll der
Flughafen in Betrieb genommen werden,
aber die Aussichten sind in
Zeiten von Covid-19 düster.
Das ist ein extremer Passagiereinbruch,
den wir natürlich jetzt erleben,
wir sind so um die
25 Prozent Passagierzahlen.
Das ist natürlich aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht
extrem schlimm.
Aus Inbetriebnahmesicht
erleichtert’s das natürlich ’n bisschen,
dass wir mit geringerer Verkehrslast
an den Start gehen können,
aber das kann dann gerne auch nach zwei,
drei Tagen alles wieder ... wieder weg sein.
Geübt wird auch ein Verkehrsunfall und
der schnelle Einsatz der Feuerwehr.
Die Flughafengesellschaft
ist mit dem Tag zufrieden.
Man verbessere sich täglich und das, obwohl
längst noch nicht alles so richtig fertig ist.
Viele Geschäfte sind noch verwaist.
Und die Komparsen?
Bis jetzt ganz gut, bis aufs Sperrgepäck,
die Abfertigungsdame sagte: nach rechts,
der Sperrgepäckschalter
hat nichts angenommen,
also durch die ganze Halle nach links,
also im Echtzeitbetrieb auch,
die Abfertigungs-, Sicherheitskontrolle und
sowas ist ziemlich langsam.
Ein Flughafen mit extrem langen Wegen,
also da müssen wir die Passagiere
darauf aufmerksam machen,
vielleicht in den Turnschuhen
und nicht in den High Heels
hier an den Flughafen zu kommen.
Ein extrem langer Weg und viele Jahre
hat es bis zur Eröffnung gedauert.
In knapp acht Wochen soll
es aber endlich soweit sein
und die ersten Flieger starten können.